hello in this video I would talk about
structure and function of bacterial cell
so bacteria are prokaryotes we cannot
see them in naked eyes so we have to use
microscope in order to see them now
bacteria doesn't have good reputation
according to the immune system so they
are like most classified criminals of
immune system and such some bacterias
like Vibrio cholerae are actually
accused with the case of causing damage
and bloody diarrhea to the body and
indeed not only cholera but also
bacteria can cause tuberculosis gastric
ulcer meningitis kynapse is leprosy
anthrax and even get typhoid so they
could be quite harmful but all that
trees are not harmful only one out of 20
bacteria turned out to be pathogenic and
bacteria are mostly harmless now you
would be amused to know that you have
more bacterias in your body than your
own body cell and these bacterias are
mostly present in your gut forming your
gut microbiome you'd be amused to know
as well that bacteria is used to produce
food beverages like alcohol vinegar etc
also bacteria could be used in sweat
sewerage treatment plant or bacteria
could be also used for biofuel
production also bacteria plays a vital
role in biological and particle research
because using the bacteria we can
perform a lot of cloning work now let's
just look at a bacterial cell the
bacterial cell has the outermost layer
which is known as the cell wall it sort
of helps that actually have to protect
it against the harsh environment and
also maintain the osmolarity balance now
inside the cytoplasm it has its genetic
material though it doesn't have any
nucleus because it's a prokaryote and
also it has the protein synthesis
machinery the 70s ribosomes now it has
some hair like appendages known as
PD and fimbriae which are important for
their reproduction and also cell
attachment to the
host cell membrane now also it has a
molecular motor which is known as
flagella which helps in chemotaxis and
bacterial motility now we would look at
the bacterial cell wall and how the cell
wall is formed so here in the bacteria
there is the cell membrane top of which
there is cell wall now the cell wall is
actually composed of two sugars one is
NS tell glucose of mine and another is
in acetyl burek acid and they're
interconnected by peptide bridges now we
would just look at how this peptide
bridges and how these interlink sugar
moieties had to form the cell wall so
everything begins in the cytoplasm of
the bacteria where there is UDP linked
n-acetylmuramic acid which is getting
attached to several peptides in
sequential reaction and forming enam
pentapeptide and that nem pentapeptide
is actually transferred to a carrier on
the membrane known as back to preneur
but the back to preneur flips it on the
outside of the cell membrane and
performs an important reaction which is
addition of UDP energy to this whole
moiety and now this basic unit for
formation of the cell wall is ready now
it can cross link with another such unit
and form a small block of the cell wall
and such units together in permutation
and combination from the whole cell wall
onto the top of the cell membrane now
based on the cell wall characteristics
bacterias could be divided into two
basic groups gram positive and gram
negative and this diffusion is basically
due to a staining method which is in
turn dependent on the cell wall
composition now the this staining method
is very simple you first apply a crystal
violet now crystal violet would coat the
bacteria in a violet color then you add
iodine and wash it with alcohol now the
bacteria who which has thinner cell wall
it will be washed away by alcohol
so it won't retain the crystal violet
stain so gram-negative bacteria has very
thin sand well compared to gram positive
bacteria that's where they cannot retain
the crystal violet stain and when they
counter stain gram negative bacteria
counter stain as pink or reddish whereas
gram positive bacteria retained their
original violet color now let's just
talk about little bit details in the
cell wall composition now you know now
gram positive bacteria has a hell lot of
thicker cell wall but as the chrome
negative bacteria hands thinner cell
wall and also outer membrane now what is
different in between gram-positive cell
wall and gram-negative cell wall is the
gram-negative cell wall the painter
peptides are linked to each other by
direct peptide bond whether in gram
positive bacteria there are specific
peptide into bridge which is connecting
the pentapeptides
and gram positive bacteria are also more
vulnerable to antibiotics now why is the
the bacterial cell wall is the most
protective structure for a bacteria now
somehow if the cell wall is disrupted
then the battery is more vulnerable to
death or destruction so let's see what
happens the whole process of the way
antibiotics work is dependent upon how
the cell wall is formed the last
reaction is the the last reaction during
the cell wall formation is the formation
of the peptide bridge between my sweat
diameter pbilic acid and the d-alanine
now this bridge formation is carried out
by transfect itís now transcript I guess
is important enzyme which carry out this
step antibiotics like penicillin blocks
this transcript is actually penicillin
has a structure of beta lactam brain
which is quite similar to the D an ally
D and an allele d-alanine which is
normally the active site of the
transpeptidase point to the d an ally
and penicillin has a similar structure
which can bind to the transcript ideas
and blocking it competitively
competitively inhibiting transcript
ideas and stopping it for from cell wall
synthesis and thereby bacteria becomes
weak and more prone to osmotic damages
and etc so that's how the antibiotic
works in my subsequent videos I will
talk about how antibiotics work and how
are other aspects of bacterial
reproduction growth and their uses so
for now this is it for this video so if
you like my video give it a thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you